Esta vez vamos a trabajar con el área de
los cuadriláteros. Vamos a hablar de los
paralelogramos, es decir: cuadrados, rectángulos y
rombos; después hablaremos del área de un trapecio
y también de los cuadriláteros que no tienen
lados paralelos, es decir, los trapezoides, y,
como caso particular, veremos las cometas.
Así que, allá vamos. Un paralelogramo es
un cuadrilátero cuyos lados opuestos son
paralelos; entre ellos tenemos al cuadrado,
al rectángulo y al rombo. Primero recordemos
cómo encontrar el área de los paralelogramos más
sencillos. Sabemos que el área de un cuadrado
es lado por lado, ¿cierto? Un cuadrado es un
paralelogramo cuyos cuatro lados y cuatro vértices
son iguales. También sabemos que el área de un
rectángulo se encuentra multiplicando su base por
su altura. Un rectángulo, como puedes ver aquí, es
un paralelogramo cuyos lados opuestos son iguales
y sus ángulos internos son todos iguales. Ahora
bien, ¿recuerdas cómo encontrar el área de un
rombo? Un rombo es un paralelogramo cuyos cuatro
lados son del mismo tamaño. Bueno, el área de un
rombo se encuentra multiplicando las longitudes
de sus diagonales y dividiendo ese resultado
entre 2. Por ejemplo, el área de este rombo será,
bueno, observa, su primera diagonal mide 12
metros, su segunda diagonal mide 14 metros y,
entonces, el área la encontramos multiplicando 12
metros por 14 metros y esto dividiéndolo entre 2,
así que el área será igual a, bueno, 12 x 14 =
168, y esto dividido entre 2 es: 84, 84 m². Bien,
ya sabemos cómo calcular el área de todos los
cuadriláteros que son paralelogramos: cuadrados,
rectángulos, rombos. ¿Pero qué pasa con los
cuadriláteros que no son paralelogramos? Bueno,
en los cuadriláteros que no son paralelogramos
no todos los lados opuestos son paralelos.
Primero tenemos a los trapecios, donde sólo
dos de sus lados opuestos son paralelos,
y para encontrar el área de un trapecio tenemos
la siguiente expresión: el área es igual a la
base mayor, más la base menor, todo esto por
la altura del trapecio, y esto dividido entre
2 (A = (B + b) h / 2) , es decir, hay que conocer
el valor de su base mayor, de su base menor y su
altura. Por ejemplo, en este trapecio tenemos que
su base mayor mide 23 milímetros, su base menor
mide 14 milímetros y su altura mide 16 milímetros,
entonces, sustituyendo los valores en la fórmula,
tenemos que el área es = (23 mm + 14 mm), todo
esto multiplicado por 16 mm y esto dividido entre
2; y esto es lo mismo que: 37 mm x 16 mm, esto
dividido entre 2. Y, bueno, si sacamos nuestra
calculadora y multiplicamos 37 x 16, y a eso
lo dividimos entre 2, nos da 296 mm², 296 mm².
Muy bien, ahora pasemos a cuadriláteros que no
tienen ningún lado paralelo a otro. Si recordamos
la diferencia entre un trapecio y un trapezoide
es que el trapecio tiene dos lados paralelos,
mientras que, en el trapezoide, ninguno de sus
lados es paralelo, es decir, los trapezoides son
cuadriláteros, tienen cuatro lados, pero ninguno
de sus lados es paralelo a otro. Primero hablemos
de un caso particular de trapezoides: las cometas
o deltoides. Una cometa es un trapezoide cuyos
lados contiguos son iguales 2 a 2, es decir,
tiene la particularidad de que dos pares de sus
lados consecutivos son iguales, siendo el primer
par de lados diferente al segundo par. Observa:
estas figuras geométricas son muy similares
a las cometas que volamos por los cielos,
así que calculemos su área y la forma de hacerlo
es similar al cálculo del área de un rombo.
Debemos fijarnos en las diagonales, ya que el área
de la cometa se encuentra como, bueno, es igual a
la multiplicación de la d₁ • d₂, esto dividido
entre 2, de igual manera que se encontraba el
área en un rombo. Si en esta cometa tenemos
como medidas una d₁ de 35 cm y una d₂ de 48 cm,
entonces el área de esta cometa será, bueno: (35
cm) (48 cm), esto dividido entre 2, y, sacando
nuestra calculadora: si multiplicamos 35 x 48 y a
eso lo dividimos entre 2, nos da 840 cm², 840 cm².
Por último, pensemos en el área de un trapezoide
en general, es decir, de un cuadrilátero que no
es un paralelogramo ni es un trapecio. ¿Habrá
forma de encontrar su área? La respuesta es sí,
y la idea de esta fórmula se basa en el área de
dos triángulos: este y este, es decir, calculando
el área de cada uno de esos triángulos obtenemos
la siguiente expresión: el A = 1/2 por la longitud
del lado a, por la longitud del lado b, por el
seno del ángulo que forman estos dos lados, es
decir, el seno de alfa más 1/2 que multiplica a la
longitud del lado c, por la longitud del lado d,
por el seno del ángulo que forman estos
dos lados, vamos a llamarlo beta (A = 1/2
ab • sen α + 1/2 cd • sen β), es decir,
multiplicaremos un medio por la longitud de los
lados consecutivos a y b, por el seno del ángulo
que forman, que llamaremos alfa, más un medio por
la longitud de los otros dos lados consecutivos,
c y d, por el seno del ángulo que forman. Así que
veamos un trapezoide en particular. Pensemos
en este de aquí. Tenemos los siguientes datos
a = 20 m, b = 16 m, c = 24 m y d = 18 m. Por su
parte, β = 60° y α = 30°, entonces, al sustituir,
tendremos que el área es igual a un medio,
que multiplica a 20 metros, que multiplica a
16 metros, por el seno del ángulo que forman estos
dos lados, es decir, el seno de 30°, más un medio,
que multiplica a 24 metros, por 18 metros, por el
seno del ángulo que forman estos otros dos lados,
es decir, el seno de 60° (A = 1/2 (20m) (16m)
• sen (30°) + 1/2 (24m) (18m) • sen (60°)), y,
si sacamos nuestra calculadora, vamos a obtener
que esto es igual a 1/2 (20 x 16) x sen (30), y a
esto le vamos a sumar 1/2 (24 x 18) sen (60); eso
es lo mismo que, bueno: 267.06 m², si redondeamos
a dos cifras significativas esto es, 267.06 m².
Perfecto, ahora ya sabemos cómo encontrar el
área de paralelogramos, es decir, ya sabemos cómo
encontrar el área de los cuadrados, rectángulos,
rombos, y también sabemos cómo encontrar el área
de un trapecio. Y además ya vimos cómo encontrar
el área de los cuadriláteros que no tienen lados
paralelos, es decir, los trapezoides, y como caso
particular vimos las cometas. Así que eso es
todo por este video. Nos vemos en el siguiente.